hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys requested as it's uh just
a brilliant brilliant attacking game it
is uh uh from the match uzbekistan
versus armenia and there is jabba
christina versus somewhere uh
uh
it's a game from board three and it's uh
well it's it's incredible yeah you guys
will enjoy it so let's dive straight
into it and then we are going to discuss
the standings uh what is happening with
the
uh with the olympia and what can still
happen which two more rounds to go so
it's a cinder with the white pieces and
he opens with pawn to e4 and we have c5
by somehow going for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 b6 and now pawn to
d4 we have captures counters so very
standard stuff here knight to f6 knight
to c3 and everyone's favorite the knight
of sicilian pawn to a6
uh and here we have bishop to d3 uh we
have quanta e5 chasing away the knight
knight back to eq and now bishop to e7
we have castles into now bishop to e6 uh
and ponte f4 again all been played
before e captures on f4 bishop
characters and now continuing
development with knight to c6 uh
not really uh not bishop captures on f4
uh in this game knight captures an f4
was played with knight and c6 and now
pawn to b3 uh preparing to fiance to the
dark square bishop on this diagonal and
there is a game that reached this exact
same position from last year's grand
chester and croatia uh and again between
jordan paul forest and even charity
where knights the e5 was played but here
we have castles and it is now acid move
11 that we have a completely new game so
uh here uh cinderella continues
development bishop to b2 we have knight
to e5 now and queen to e1 with uh the
queen now having access to f2 to g3 to
h4 and maybe even an attack against the
black king if the bishops come alive uh
somehow
uh so here rook to yeah you could also
capture the bishop but for the moment
this bishop is a pawn you don't really
gain anything by capturing this and your
knight here is an excellent piece so
this would be pretty pointless so rook
to e8 and now king to h1 always a useful
move not allowing any uh future queen to
b6 or bishop c5 ideas uh we have bishop
to f8 now preparing g6 and bishop to g7
to strengthen the black king's position
and rook to d1 now we have pawn to g6
and pawn to h3 taking away the g4 square
from so many black pieces uh rook to c8
and now queen to f2 so nicely continuing
development then here you can see uh
that uh javakian has a plan of bringing
the knight over to b6 and there's really
not all that much black can do about
this if he doesn't wanna
uh ruin his position too much so bishop
g7 knight to a4 going after this plan
queen e7 and now knight to b6 attacking
this rook we have rook to c6 and now
comes a move that i really really enjoy
it is uh one of those moves that are
just
extremely aesthetically pleasing and
that is bishop to b4 just uh
centralizing the bishop the bishop now
here uh slices the entire board uh it's
it's it's a monster bishop and um
it really belongs here due to the rook
now being on c6 preventing the knight
from coming to c6 so as long as the rook
is here your bishop is on d4 so queen to
c7 now putting pressure on the knight
but the knight is already sufficiently
defended so no worries there queen the
g1 opening up the f file for the rook
and now comes queen to e7 uh this is
basically uh a moment where uh samuel
has to make a decision where he wants to
finally capture on b3 and go into this
forcing line uh because queen the g1
does allow knight captures on d3 and it
wins upon regardless of how white
recaptures point is that if knight
captures on d3 if you play c characters
on d3 they have the very strong center
then knight captures an e4 becomes an
option
and now what is happening here we are
attacking the bishop here and once we
eliminate the bishop then we can pick up
the knight the knight is defended by the
bishop and by the queen so if you
capture the knight of course bishop
captures on the four queen captains and
queen captures on b6 we will always uh
win the spawn so maybe he was afraid of
something like queen f6 and then maybe
something i don't know it doesn't seem
like a white has all that much and that
white can
create some sort of an attack but uh
it's definitely a possibility maybe with
something like knight to h5 you
sacrifice the knight because checkmate
is being threatened maybe rooker 3 rook
to g3 so there are ideas and of course
uh
he he thinks that maybe syndrome has
this prepared another thing after knight
captures and e3 you can play rook
characters on d3
but it's not much better not just knight
captures an e4 not knight f to d5
attacking the queen and if bishop
captures knight characters again
attacking the queen for example queen a5
pawn to c4 again a possibility uh the
variation ends here uh it's it's pretty
equal position black will always be up
upon so
those were
samus options if he wants to capture on
d3 but he wants to keep everything in
the game he continues with queen to e7
and now pawn to c4 just strengthening
the position getting rid of the the
the pawn on c2 and knight f d7 now uh
offering a trade of knights so knight to
beat the d5 now attacking the queen and
the queen to h4 uh now the queen is a
very active here so bishop f2 kicking
away the queen queen g5 and now bishop
to e3 threatening some very nasty
discoveries queen back to h4 bishop to
f2 queen to h6 now somehow not
interested in repeating the position he
wants to continue playing bishop to g3
and now we have queen to g5 again
playing with the queen harassing the
bishop and g3 much stronger with g5 here
it's a classical game so we can show a
few more lines the point is that now uh
once the knight captures uh on an e6 we
recapture and we force this knight back
knight before now attacks the rook rook
c the c8 and the game continues with uh
with good chance for both sides however
here after queen to g5 this is where
things get extremely interesting queen
to f2 now with ideas of bishop to h4 uh
attacking the black queen so queen back
to d8 which was the original plan and
now quanta a4 we look back to c8 now
preparing to bring the knight over to c6
and now this should be back to c2 now
you are not capturing this bishop and
javakir has a very very interesting plan
of how to get this bishop to come alive
so rook to f8 now preparing to maybe uh
open up the position with f5 now comes
knight to the e3 adding a defender after
the f5 square
knight to c5 and now comes the move uh
that you guys have seen in the thumbnail
and that is knight to f5 and this is a
brilliant move uh just a spectacular
idea uh strongest move recommended by
the engine and it really shows how how
strong white's position is and even the
bishop on c2 has some sort of a function
so your options are to capture the
knight which is strongest and to maybe
play knight captures an e4 yeah this is
if you want to accept the piece and go
uh and you know start defending and this
is if you want to keep material balance
so if you go knight captures on e4 the
shot captures the shock captures on f5
we're still going to open up the black
king now go knight d5 and well you
haven't really achieved anything you
black is upon but with the king
completely wide open like this
uh it's very hard to imagine black
surviving this so after knight to f5 we
have g captures on f5 uh samuel accepts
the peace sacrifice we have e captures
on f5 and bishop back to d7 and now
comes knight to h5 and this is uh
knight to h5 is the uh a simple way to
go for the win i will show a forcing
line as this is what we also do on the
channel rook captures and d6 now
preparing the f6 is also very very
strong if queen d7 unpinning now we just
play f6 we sacrifice the rook here and
after queen captures pawn captures here
rook after e8 and now knight to h5 so
this is the line uh javakir just put the
knight on h5 first so he can yeah you
know skip a few moves
but by doing so he allowed this f6
defensive idea in that variation so here
for example f5 uh to prevent knight to
f6 check but now we just trade
everything bishop counters characters
counters and again there's no defense
against knight f6 check if knight b7 uh
you still just eliminate one of the
knights now you are threatening queen to
f7 the knight was defending f7 and if
knight captures then knight f6 check and
the position just falls apart captures
here with checking if eight knight to d7
will be a double check and also a
checkmate
so that's in the position
however knight to h5 is a much much
simpler idea as it threatens b4 i know
you guys will think i'm i'm you know
joking because i always mentioned the b4
move
but you can see that the knight has no
squares once b4 is played the knight is
just uh lost and again if you try to
stop that then f6 is coming then it's
game over so here f6 has to be played
and now point to b4 just wins the knight
so here black has to decide how to give
back the knight he decides to give it
back by knight to c to d3
uh at least the white will have to give
up the light square bishop so bishop
characters here bishop countersun a4
attacks the rook rook to d2 and now
bishop to h6 attacking the rook uh
hoping that the rook moves so we can
capture the bishop here but just bishop
the f4 countering the dark square bishop
we have characters captures now going
for that e6 square and another fork rook
to f7 and now pawn to c5 beautifully
played just opening up the
uh the d file for the rook of course if
you capture then all sorts of nasty
discoveries become possible uh so here
just knight characters on d3 and rook
characters and e3 we have bishop back to
c6 and now rook captures on d6
completely busting open the position
queen to f8 and now knight to e6
attacking the black queen queen h6 now
comes rook f2 d1
and this is incredible rook after d1
just cold bloodedly allowing queen
captures on h3 because even if you play
this just king g1 and there's no uh move
that you can make here yeah the queen is
attacked once the queen moves rook one
to the three now the rook comes into the
attack uh javits are playing this with
um uh with absolute clean just uh you
know perfection so rook to e8 and now
comes king to h2 not allowing queen
captures an h3 anymore and leaving black
without a move rook after e7 was played
now rook one to d4 going for for the
attack with king the h8 and now rook to
h4 attacking the black queen queen to c1
and now queen to d4 threatening queen
captures on f6 rook to f7 defending and
now rook to d8 and he was in this
position animal 49 that uh
somehow
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here uh whatever you play
doesn't really matter let's say try
queen e1 because what all of your pieces
are pinned uh we can just counter
captures counters and now rookie four we
kick away the queen and then we go for
the bishop and that's it let's say queen
c1 queen queen to d8 and there is no
defense against queen captures uh bishop
on e8
uh so i'm really an incredible attacking
game by java kucinda of abort 3 for
uzbekistan this is what happened on all
the other boards uh if you guys are
interested so you can see abu satra drew
against sergiyan on board one and go to
yakubu drew against welcoming uh onboard
three we've seen this how cinderella
defeated teresa and the bucket of
defeated uh
on board for so uh uzbekistan just
crashes through armenia and is now are
now the sole leaders of the chest
olympia 2022 there are two more runs to
go armenia and india too led by lukas
are one point behind so anything can
still happen
uh uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it really uh spectacular
spectacular attacking game uh i would
like to thank um
who will be joshua hadley uh
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the olympiad until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day